what's the deal what are they actually
partnering on here so air Bumi is going
to offer through certain flights people
who fly on virgin and then end up at an
Airbnb destination will then be able to
earn some elevate point elevators
infinity program for virgin america
which i know so well excite yes julian
went flying castilian elevate points
understand and it's interesting because
it's a different kind of business than
it used to be mean they are at a very
different place that a Airbnb is than
they were before so for that metal show
is virgin america but virgin america is
a much more established brand that means
something to a certain kind of consumer
listen to a jonathan Mildenhall wanted
to say about sort of the way that this
is a growth company way cmom chief
marketing officer of Airbnb check this
out we started off obviously is quite a
nice traveler proposition but we've
grown tremendously over the last seven
years it took us four years to go from
guess number one to guess number a
million and this year we'll end up
having 60 million travelers travel on
air being 80 million 60 million
travelers different people different
different people from the beginning to
now and so as we continue to scale we
become more mainstream traveler
proposition and that gives us license to
partner with more mainstream travel
brands as we've got more to offer and
partners such as virgin america kind of
amazing and you know we wanted to talk
about sort of the way the business works
and how they see themselves you know the
CEO of Airbnb tweeted famously tweeted
something out about a year ago saying
we're going to in a marriott just to
made a big announcement how many hotel
rooms are going to add in the next three
years we're going to add more than that
in the next three weeks more rooms and
so i asked him how did they look at
themselves within the company in the
weather they market themselves are they
staying in someone's living room or are
they an alternative to a hyatt or a
hilton or a Sheraton or a starwood even
and how are they going to market
themselves going forward listen nobody
had to say we like to think that we're
additive to at the overall market
but this year we will close on having
two million properties on the Airbnb
platform so we've basically doubled in
size versus last year our occupancy rate
can go from anything to a hundred
percent occupancy in a city like San
Francisco to seasonable as seasonal
occupancy in a city like Orlando that's
interesting because Airbnb is going to
be on the ballot in Sanford for San
Francisco voters and prop have the
opponents are saying that they're taking
away long term rentals well if you think
about that when I was talking to a
friend today about sort of low-income
housing in San Francisco and what
low-income housing what a city can do to
determine what they want to be in should
a city for example provide low-income
housing or well i would i would argue
absolutely i should because it helps it
helps the city have the character that
you want and isn't that supposed to be
one of adelaide's big things and yet if
you let people rent things at a market
rate by definition it's not low income
anymore it becomes whatever you want it
to be Jeff I mean how how concerned are
you about the the regulatory issues
surrounding air B&B these kinds of
battles that they continue to have to
have to fight not just in San Francisco
but really do two most interesting serve
on g-man companies both uber and Airbnb
are skating really really fast but they
also sort of taking those those sort of
realtor issues I think that because she
put in the same bucket though by them I
know right he does huh but at the same
time if they actually are in you know in
front of a ballot where some people are
trying to sort of limit how much of
those rooms or sort of i am apartments
can be put on a B&B so I think and
depending two million dollars in this
one local elections and went to win this
battle because because San Francisco is
really sort of home turf they have to
win it well or could be the model for
other cities want to be going forward so
I think the issue when we think about
those those investments is how much of
the regulatory framework do we have to
compete against try and change and in
their case they can have to sort of find
us that balance between the need to have
low income housing but also the need for
them to be able to scale
and it's gonna be treated Cory you also
spoke to Branson yeah talk to you a
little bit about his is he an investor
in air baby he is not an investor
everything me as far as i know but i was
surprised to find out that he was
investor in uber and the way that he
made that investment we were talking
about necker island talking about sort
of building a brand and talking what
goes on in necker island I've heard lots
of stories some of which we can talk
about so much we can't they will talk
about a map camera off camera but he
talked about making the investment while
he was standing at the bar at necker
island and deciding right then and there
to make them listen this is how Richard
Branson invest jugar i ended up
investing in at the bar on Necker Airbnb
there's a wonderful new company called
called ring which which I invested in at
that the bar on Becca that's exploding
here in America and saving lots of
people from being broken and entered
into tell me you got more of the story
there we are tell me you got oh we saw
there as I'm a benefit last night for a
benefit of the ocean and trying to get
ray there is six hundred thousand
dollars in San Francisco this benefit
last night I saw Branson there and yes
there were some stories and there are
some lots of good to the bar get
investment from Brent said yeah